Since the beginning of time, burn has
been one of the most iconic archetypes
in Magic. But unfortunately, it does not
translate well into commander at all.
One mana for three damage is great when
your opponent is at 20 life, but a lot
worse when you have three opponents at
40 each. So, for years, burn has been
relegated to being the butt of jokes.
The punch line, yeah, I'll build burn,
you'll build conflict, right? Haha. But
in 2025, this is the year we turn that
laughter into screams and the smell of
Fyrexian
barbecue. Snowfim Mayhem Dominus is the
perfect burn commander. Efficient,
difficult to remove, and scales so well
to the format. He gave me the confidence
to take burn as far as I can in
commander. Maybe maybe we can tussle
with the big boys, the biggest boys in
bracket 4. We'll see.
So, let's take a closer look at soulium.
The first ability here, doubling all
non-combat damage allows us to play a
ton of symmetrical burn spells. For
example, a rolling earthquake for three
will keep soulium alive while dealing
six to all your opponents. And if you
want to go bigger or if your opponent
starts targeting sulfium, we can always
use the second ability to discard two
cards and give them indestructible. Now,
in model red, discarding two can hurt
can hurt a lot. So, we need some cards
to help recoup this loss. We will share
them later. But yeah, speaking of honor
red, we really have the short end of the
stick here. Everything is difficult up
here in the mountains. You have the
worst card draw, the worst spot
removals, mediocre ramp, pretty much
below average everything. Now, to bridge
this gap, we'll need to borrow the power
of colorless. And for some reason,
colorless is just better than red at
most things. So, this deck unfortunately
will be relatively high cost in terms of
budgeting. Uh, but in terms of playing,
it's not too difficult. The play style
is fairly straightforward, although you
would have to gouge when to do things
and when to when to lay low. Uh, because
I want to mention that I see a lot of
list online playing these really
aggressive almost group slug effects
like what's it called? Sulfuric vortex.
Yeah. And you can play that early with
sophium. you can put a lot of pressure
on your opponents, but in this deck, we
are avoiding that just because in a
group that knows what they're doing,
when you run out of the gate like that,
things will get answered. Your commander
will get removed. And when you're
playing mono red, you can't really trade
resource like that with your opponents,
right? Imagine not even three, just one
or two opponents gunning you down
because you're taking taking out their
life total. You will not come out ahead
most likely. So in this deck, what we're
doing is for the most part, we are
laying low accumulating resources. And
once we build up the resource, we can
find the chance, the opportunity to have
one huge explosive turn uh with burn
spells or with something else. And if
that works, sure, maybe our opponent's
half dead. We just need maybe two burn
spells to kill them. But if not, then we
back off again. We answer things. We
control the board and look for a second
chance. So, with no further ado, we are
going to start with the deck. But please
like and subscribe, but more
importantly, please let me know if you
prefer this style over the animated
style of
videos. All right, to start things off,
we have a pile of cards for resource
accumulation. Now, this is card draw,
ramp, and all that. This actually 30
cards. is interesting because when I was
building this deck, I had a kind of a
skeleton and then I played this deck for
over a year, probably more than 30, 40
games just to test things and whatever I
felt like was missing, I would cut cards
and exchange and upgrade. And I didn't
really count how many of each card I
have until today when I realized I have
more than 30 or maybe 29 around around
30 of these resource gathering cards.
And honestly, just building the deck
from scratch, I would never do this. But
it seems like this is what we need for
the deck to function, to power the deck.
Um, this is like the vegetables.
Unfortunately, again, in other colors,
you wouldn't need this many. You would
need maybe 15 to 20, but in this case,
in mono red, we kind of have to play
these to to get everything to work as
intended. So, starting off we have ramp
and first we have of course soaring
uh mindstone arcane sign. Nothing too
special here. The glare I think this is
okay. All right. Glittering stockpile is
worth talking about just because uh it's
the competition for three mana rock is
fears. They print so many good ones. But
what's nice about this is I think it
fits our play style well because this
allows us to store mana. And if this can
stay around for a while, it can easily
you can easily crack it for four to five
mana to power out one of those big
turns, which is nice cuz again our play
style, we are laying low and then once
in a while, boom, take a big turn and
then lay low again and take another big
turn. And this card fits that. Commander
Sphere, Thrand Dynamo, one of the best
mana rocks, I'd say, in mono colored,
but not better than throne of Eldra.
Throne of Eldrin is just ridiculous.
Five mana now typing for four. the only
the restriction of only being able to
play the colored spell is a bit
annoying. It can definitely come up, but
I mean you play this on turn five,
untapping on turn six with 10 mana,
which is just ridiculous. And also the
draw effect is not the best, especially
considering how this uh the throne taps
for four mana. So you're paying seven
mana to draw two, but in a pinch I've
activated this before. Yeah. So
definitely can come up. Next up,
navigation orb. Five mana cultivate.
This is quite expensive for what it
does, but again, I am huge on hitting
your land drops. And usually, you know,
by turn five, turn six, you are starting
to miss land drops. So, using this
basically gets you two lands, right? Cuz
if you again, if you get a landing hand
when you don't have a land, that's a ram
spell. So, yeah, I still think it's
pretty good when I played it. Next up,
burnish chart. even more expensive, even
clunkier, but man, just getting two lens
into play. This is not something monor
gets to do and it feels so good. So,
it's it's still
in solemn similar never feels bad to
draw. I mean, it's getting kind of power
crept, right? There are better cards
now, but again, in mono red, we are our
standards are lower definitely. And
yeah, it's a perfectly serviceable card.
Pendant of Prosperity. This card I
talked about in a video. I've actually
never got to cast this card cuz I just
added it. Uh I've seen my opponents use
it to to to great effect and on paper
this card is just ridiculous. Uh so
maybe you're not so familiar with this
card. We'll read it. This so when you
cast it, it enters the battlefield under
the control of an opponent of your
choice and pay two. So now the opponent
can activate this ability. You cannot.
They can pay two to basically explore.
But when they do that, you can do the
same. You can draw a card and put a land
onto the battlefield. Not tapped.
So even if your opponent just activates
this once, you got your pretty much
three mana value back. And sure, you can
do politics, you can make deals, but
because I mean, if I'm on the table,
someone plays this, I would want it and
I would want to activate it because if I
don't, someone else takes it, I'm really
far behind. Yeah. So it's the politics
is huge here. But even if you don't want
to do politics, you can just give it to
someone with spare mana, right? someone
with uh open mana that that doesn't seem
like they're using, they're just going
to pass it on tap. Yeah, give it to
them. It's hard for anyone to resist the
temptation of this free value. And also,
if you see someone struggling mana
screw, give it to them. So, yeah, this
card I can see it being incredible. Glet
of Might. So, now it comes to three
mana. Now, this is definitely not
necessary. This is like half the budget
of the deck. So I I think honestly I
think two power uh two metal wars is
enough cuz these are super high-risisk
high reward. You play them usually you
won't be doing too much that turn and
then your opponent will most likely try
to remove them but if they don't you get
one of those huge turns. So I do think
two should be enough or you can play uh
what's it called? Extra pet planer lens
but that one is a little bit riskier.
Yeah. Gallet gauntlet and cage sun. Cage
Sun is six mana, but it's nice because
it allows your non-basic lands to tap
for red to also tap for double. So yeah,
you pay more, you get more. Next up,
spiteful repossession. This is not a
burn spell. This is actually a a ram
spell because if you read it, um the
floor is not high because sometimes you
your opponents don't have more lands
than you. But when they do, we don't
need that many cuz we can on the turn we
play this, we don't have to drop the
land. We can play this first. Now, with
Sophium on the field, even if your
opponents are one or two lands more than
you, you're easily making four to six
treasures. Now, if one or even two
opponents are playing green, you are
going off. Yeah, this can easily be used
as a ritual almost. You're getting your
mana back or you can store the mana for
future
turns. This is uh manager. Yeah,
manager. Uh yeah, the big big red. I
think the most iconic spell in Big Red.
um you are making mid game easily 10
meta net 10 meta and this can power out
a huge turn. You can either finish your
opponents with big X spells or you can
just play a lot of things cuz in this
deck cards are expensive and for us to
get utility it costs just extra mana
because we are relying again a lot on
colorless stuff. So manager seems good.
Season of the bold this card doesn't do
too much but is like a bit of
everything. Now the third mode I don't
find it to be too useful. it can be okay
but I uh because we don't have a lot of
small spells that we are and also two
damage becomes four is only hitting
creatures is not that much so usually
the typical use for this would be pay
two paw here to get uh two cards for two
turns for this turn and next turn and at
the same time getting three top treasure
tokens for five mana I think it's
reasonable value yeah because you're
getting cards and mana to use the cards
for next turn next
Theatic Compass. Again, I talked about
this. This card is, I think, super
underrated just because, again, if
you're ramping and missing land drops,
what's the point? You I think it's
better for you to just tap three mana to
basically it's like a Dark Soul Inca,
right? Every three mana you pay, you can
get a land and play it. And more
importantly, late game or mid game
actually, this can flip into a maze of
if a better maze of. So for two mana you
basically it's like repenting growth but
you get a really really good land. So I
think this card is definitely worth
playing in especially mono color decks
without
green. Next up command. This is one of
the best resource accumulation cards
here because this is this can be done at
instant speed and the other modes are
flexible. Right? Because for a lot of
the other cards, you're making
treasures, but you're doing doing it on
your turn and you're spending mana, so
your shields are down. But with this, it
basically doubles your mana, right?
Well, minus two. And then you can say
create 10 Aldrazi sound tokens and untap
with 18 mana. But at the same time,
you're also keeping your options open,
right? If you have to kill something,
you can remove exotic creature or
graveyard hate. But if none of that
comes up, we can just dig for a big
spell, right? So, we are making a bunch
of chump blockers. We're making a bunch
of uh Aldrazi spawn that can crack for
mana. And we're also digging for a big
burst spell to use with that mana. So,
this is honestly one of the best new
cards for this
deck. Jessica's Will. Not much to say
about this. Just a ridiculous magic
card. Uh we have I think five game
changers in here. So, we are bracketed
four, but I believe two of them are
pretty cutable or not necessary in this
deck. This one is though. This one is
just
amazing. Big score. And because so now
we're going into card filtering because
our deck we have lots of small stuff
that we don't want late game and lots of
large huge spells that we don't want
early game. So being able to filter the
cards is nice. Like for example, early
game you draw a a huge burn spell, you
probably want to discard it. At the same
time, late game if you draw a arcane
signant, you can discard that and draw
two cards. And also storing two mana for
you is super
relevant. Uh yeah, unexpected windfall.
Same card. I'm not playing the instant
uh the sorcery speed once only the
instance because uh in this deck we are
operating we're trying our best to
operate at instant speed to be able to
respond to things. So, keeping your
options open, you know, you respond if
you have to. If you don't, then you do a
windfall, I think, is the best best way
to
approach. Uh, risk factor. Yeah, risk
factor. It's a cool card. I mean, it's
Punisher. A lot of people don't like it,
but when your opponents see you're
playing a burn deck, they usually
probably wouldn't want to take eight
damage, especially not another eight
from the jump start. So chances are you
you get to draw at least three cards
from casting it and jump starting it
which is decent and you also just burned
you know eight damage. Also there are
times where you don't want them to let
you draw. You want to burn for that
eight. So both sides can be useful and
overall I think the value is decent and
especially considering that you can
discard it right to Sophia or other
discard effects and it can still be
relevant in the graveyard. So I think
overall this card is fairly fairly good
in this deck. Next up sandstone Oracle
to refill our hand. This is the price we
have to pay in monor red. This is
actually pretty good because early game
again we are dropping lots of mana
rocks. We are discarding to sophium. So
to refill our hand is nice. Mid game
usually some someone is at you know six
cards. Maybe someone is at 12. Sometimes
you hit the jackpot but usually this
card can help you refill pretty well.
And sure the cost seems expensive but
it's actually not so bad in this deck
especially if you look at the next
card. Yeah, this is for revealing our
hand and it's a decent threat and kind
of a control piece. Even though this
Kaik draws more hate than it deserves. I
mean, I'm I'm not countering anything
that's not hurting me, right? But
usually your opponents are like, "Oh,
Ka'ala is there. He's going to counter
everything. We have to kill." Uh, you
don't you don't just don't target my
stuff. And yeah, again, this is 10 mana,
but with the kind of ramp and
acceleration we have, we can get this
down pretty much turn six, turn seven,
the latest, and that's usually when you
need to refill. So, yeah, great card.
Cross it up to seven. Next up, yes, the
one ring, of course. Now, the one ring,
I I'll be honest with you. I think the
one ring commander is a better format
with the one ring band just because it's
so ridiculous. You can take any deck
pretty much take out a card from the 99
and put this in and the deck is arguably
better. Now, I try not to play the one
ring in any deck that doesn't have
player synergy with it. But in uh
Sophium, I think it makes a lot of sense
just because you can play it and then
you can burn the table. Meanwhile, you
are untouched. And at the same time, we
do need the card draw to be able to keep
up with those blue and green decks.
Yeah. So they will help us bridge the
gap a little bit. Next up, the
wheels, misfortune, fortune, and rune
horn. Okay. So when I was saying earlier
how the gauntlet of might was like half
the budget, wheel of fortune is another
I'd say 20%. So if you cut wheel and
gauntlet, this deck is actually fairly
budget friendly, I'd say. And wheel is
honestly not necessary. It's a great
card, but I I think honestly rune horn
Hkite is better. And we're playing
wheels once again because we are
discarding and we are dumping our hand
fast. Usually I don't play wheels
because they're risky. They're refilling
your opponents. But in this case, it
makes a lot of sense. A real horn is the
best one because you can discard it and
use it later. And also being instant
speed is huge because when you wheel,
you always want to be the first person
to use those cards, right? So even
though it's six mana, I think it's more
than worth it. Yeah. Wheels.
And that's all for our what's it called?
Resource accumulation cards. Yes. And
again, it's about 29 to 30 of
them. This is the vegetable. We have to
eat it. But now we can make time for
some fun
stuff. So now it's time for the fun
part. And here is the core of the deck.
That is our game plan. the cards that
help us advance our plan, including
removals that allow us to control the
game and also uh burn stuffs, finishers,
too. So, let's start off with Guff Reise
History. Now, this one is like Chaos
Warp, which I have, but Guff Rice
History is, I think, a bit underrated.
Sure, it cannot deal with enchantments,
but at the same time, you can do one
permanent per opponent, and you can even
do some something from your own board,
right? Because we have a lot of
treasures, we can just tuck a treasure
and hope to hit something big. Or, you
know, if your one ring becomes too big
and taking you're taking too much
damage, you can tuck the one ring. So, I
think this is a premium removal in red.
And of course, we have chaos
warp. Blasphemous
act. Pretty pretty typical, but in this
deck actually, blasphemous act can be
used to win games when comboed with some
of the cards we'll go over later. And
next up, chain reaction. I really don't
want to play this card because it's I
mean it's poor mana. It's not even cheap
and it's inconsistent. Sometimes you
don't kill what you need to kill. But
unfortunately in red for I think they
just printed blasphemous act and then
forgot about red. So they didn't really
upgrade the removal of the board wipes.
So we still have to play this until
wizards remembers us again I guess. Next
up is starstorm. Starstorm is pretty
much the best removal next to blast I'd
say. And because mostly because of the
instant speed and also when you have
soulium on the board, you don't have to
pay too much mana into X. Yeah. And
cycling is nice too. So just overall a
really really efficient piece that uh
also quite
flexible. Spiteful mandatory. This is
like uh the red what's it called? Meat
hook massacre. Yes, exactly like that.
because when it enters, you can deal X
damage to each creature and then for
each creature that dies, you get a
treasure. It's a lot of power. Except
this is not like me hook because it only
triggers once a turn. It's actually a
lot worse. But just getting the one
treasure from cast and then once in a
while the treasure there, a treasure
here. It's not bad. So again, decent
removal and all this damage based stuff
is doubled by recommener. Why not? Next
up, Reckless Endeavor. This card is
ridiculous. Yeah, I rolled two d20s. I
mean, sometimes, I mean, last time I
played, I remember I rolled a one and a
three, but even then, with the help of
our commander, we still wiped the board
and got one treasure. And once in a
while, you just get hit the jackpot cuz
the the board wipe side choosing uh the
number you choose for board wipe doesn't
have to high. It doesn't have to be high
when you have sulfium. It can just be
three or four and then you can maximize
the treasure output which can be super
useful for our big turns. Oblivion stone
uh the old staple from 15 years ago even
maybe even older. Uh but still we have
to play it. I know we have a lot of
artifacts. We have a lot of permanence
too but unfortunately we just can't
answer some of the permanent based decks
like for example imagine super friends.
Imagine sagas you just cannot deal with
them. So, we need a panic button and
that's what Obliv Stone is. I don't want
to use it, but when I have to, I will.
And after that is Ugan. Now, this is
just a I think one of the best board
wipes in decks that are I think with
lots of artifacts, right?
And especially if we don't have a lot of
permanence any color. Yeah, Ugan just
wipes. It's almost like a one-sided
board wipe most of the time. It kills
our commander, but everything else on
our board pretty much stays for the most
part. And yeah, in mono red, you do need
something like
this. Next up, we are starting to not
just burn creatures, but also players.
Electro dominance is the first one. It's
a bit expensive, not super efficient,
but what's nice is the flexibility. It's
instant. It can target place walkers,
creatures, players, and also you can use
this to drop something. It allows you to
cast a spell with mana value X or less.
So imagine electro dominance something
for five and then dropping a gauntlet of
power at the end of turn and then you
untap with double mana and you can win
from there. So it's not super efficient
but it's got some play and some tricks
that you can do. A rolling earthquake.
This is the only earthquake I play. I
don't play actual earthquake cuz I want
to be able to kill fires. Now if someone
pulls out a portal 3 kingdom deck
against me, I will cry. But generally,
this is also a decent win condition and
a perfectly serviceable board weapon.
The roller crusher
ride. Now, Delirium happens in our deck,
but not super quickly. So, I'm
evaluating this card just based on the
second ability. When it enters, it deals
X damage to each of up to three target
creatures. That's already a pretty good
removal ability, right? Getting three
targets. Unfortunately, you cannot burn
players,
but yeah, just being able to remove
things and usually nobody would target
it, right? Because it's not on, but when
it's online, when you combine this with
your uh commander with Sophium, we're
dealing four times damage. So, yeah,
it's a pretty nice removal with a high
ceiling. I like
that. Delayed blast fireball. It's got
four tail and uh you can pay six to deal
five damage to each opponent and each
creature they control. And with our
commander, it is 10 damage. In a pinch,
you can also use the three mana version,
which is two damage times two, four with
our commander. Uh but unfortunately, we
only have one for tile card in this
deck, so our opponents know what it is,
but it is pretty efficient at what it
does. And also, we do have a ton of
exile based synergy. Like we can exile
cards from the top, we can cast from
exile. So yeah, I think this card is
quite good all things considered. Miku
spark, which is Chandra's ignition. When
you target that onto our commander, it
is 10 damage to everything and each
opponent, right? Just a really efficient
explosive damaging spell and board wipe.
It's a bit risky because your opponents
can target our commander in response
with removal, but again, we have an
indestructible, so it's less risky this
way. Molten Disaster. This is probably
my favorite card in this deck just
because it completely changes how the
game works cuz usually I I'm sure you've
all seen those late game players with
probably Simic decks where they can pass
the turn holding up 12 mana with three
counter spells and two removals and they
feel invincible and this is the card you
get them with split second and there's
nothing they can do unless there's a
there's a morph for something but yeah,
there's pretty much nothing your
opponents can do once you put this on
the stack.
So this is something we need in the late
game just to get get around counter
spells, get around all the responses and
yeah finish the game. Comet storms nice
instant speed. Usually this itself won't
be killing your opponents but what's
nice is you can end a turn comet storm
for say 14 to 16 damage and then untap
to do the killing that you can surprise
kill and imagine opponents sitting at 30
life feeling pretty safe. Yeah, you can
get them with
this Gas Emilating Inferno. This one is
not as good. Still decent just because
of how efficient it is. Three targets,
right? When you when you're doubled in
the mid game to late game, you can
easily deal 10 to 20 damage to each
opponent and that can kill people and
also in a pinch as a removal.
Unfortunately, you do need your
commander to turn this on. So, this
might be one of the weaker burn spells,
but for now, it's still serviceable.
Krakco with power on the other hand is
probably one of the strongest burn
spells here. Yeah, the way it scales is
this is a card this is a burn spell
designed for commander. Yeah, cuz you
have to do the math. But uh maybe I
should have done it earlier, but the
math works out as if you pay say 11
mana, it is 15 damage to each opponent.
If you pay is it 14? Yeah, 14 mana, it
is 20 damage to each opponent. And with
her commander, all that is doubled. you
can easily finish the game with just
this one card. Now, this next card here
is a bit of a curveball. Sometimes it
will do nothing, but when it's good,
it's really, really good. You can finish
the game. For example, if you're
casting, so I say an earthquake for
five, and then you target, for example,
sophium with this. And what happens is
sophium will take 10 damage from
earthquake and arc bond will double that
again, which is 20 damage to everything.
Every player, well, not you because it's
half for you, but it's double for your
opponents. So, with that play, you just
dealt
10 plus 20 damage to each opponent and
each creature on the
board. Yeah. So, super explosive and can
get people out of nowhere. Just three
mana. Pyrohemia. This is one of the best
uh I say best enchantments in the deck.
The best I say stacks pieces almost cuz
with this and sofium on the board, no
one is keeping creatures, right? They
cannot do anything because sophium is
indestructible. So it's Parhemia won't
die and until they answer one of these
two permanent their life will keep going
down and they will not be able to stick
any creature anything on the board.
Parromia man barbar is the only I'd say
uh stacksish enchantment that I play
that is only only for the damage just
because it does so much damage. It's
Yeah. I mean, if your opponent is
ramping each turn, they're probably
taking 10 to 20 damage just to cast
their things, and they cannot afford to
do that. So, with this on the board,
your opponent really, their clock is
ticking for them, and they have to
answer this or sophium or watch their
life go down because it is two damage
per land when
doubled. Now, repercussion. This is
almost like a combo piece. And this is
what works with our board wipes. Usually
when I play this and a boardweight, the
game is finished because the damage is
doubled from the boardweight to the
creature and then when it goes through
repercussion and it's directed to the to
the controllers, it's doubled again. And
once again, this is only for your
opponents because it doesn't doesn't
happen for us. So yeah, this is one of
the bigger win conditions. And also
Mystics Mastery, we are not a spelling
deck, but we have a lot of spells. And
the base mode of just four mana to
recast a spell from graveyard is already
good. But late game, if you can overload
it, if you have a full graveyard and
overload it, the game is pretty much
over. You get so much value. You get so
much mana that Yeah. So, I think Misix's
Masquery is a solid card even though it
doesn't like on the on paper, it doesn't
have too much synergy with what we're
doing here. And next up, Dictate of the
Twin Gods. I don't like symmetrical
effects just because in mono red we
don't have much life gain and we can die
pretty quickly and this doubling damage
to everyone is risky but the flash is
what changes things cuz end of turn you
flash and untap you have a decent chance
of just finish the game right there. Uh
because you have sulfium plus this
that's four times damage any burn spell
will
do. So yeah dictative twing gods but do
not play
this. So yeah, dictated twin goss. Don't
just drop it. Only drop it when you're
ready to finish the
game. Torough god of fury. This is quite
similar to repercussion from earlier. It
is worse, but it's a it's a decent body.
And um yeah, and any damage any excess
damage is dealt to your opponents. Once
again, we we do that double double which
can turn any board weapon into a lot of
damage. And lastly, fiery emancipation.
This is the backup for our commander if
it dies too much. Yeah, it's six mana
expensive. If you drop it, you probably
have a turn where you have to wait and
hopefully your opponents don't blow this
up. But if they don't, again, any burn
spell will probably finish the game. So,
this is the package of burn control and
all that. And this is how we win the
game.
Next up, we have some miscellaneous
utility. All right, next up we have some
miscellaneous utility. Just uh let's say
protection for our commander. Soot
boost, lightning grease. Can you see?
Yep. And deflection swap of course. Bolt
band almost as good as deflecting swat.
And then Tibol's trickery. Yeah, you can
really get people with it. The red
counter spell. Next up, Malcanori. I
think this card is I mean there's a lot
of debate around this card but in this
deck I think it's excellent. The
reasoning is that when you are when
you're playing at a disadvantage when it
comes to, you know, your value engines
and your card draw and stuff, how you
how you bridge that gap is through
better decision- making. And Valkconori
allows us to make better decisions
because we have time, right? We don't
play the cards until we absolutely have
to, which is huge in multiplayer. So, I
think this is definitely worthy of a
spot in this deck. And lastly, we have
Underworld Breach. Now, this is one of
the game changers that I don't think is
necessary. So, on paper, it's amazing,
but when I played it, it's been a decent
value piece. It's like a, you know, it's
like a regrowth, but it's never a game
ending just because of, you know, exotic
three cards from our grave. And also,
our spells are not cheap. So, it's I
usually use it as a regrowth. But
sometimes if you have something like,
for example, Jessica's will or manager
in your graveyard, this can definitely
go off. So yeah, we're I'm still testing
this card, but I do think it's not
again, if you care about game changers,
this is not necessary in the deck. And
finally, we're on to lands.
And I believe we have 38 lens in this
deck and a lot a lot of non-basics
because if you're playing against some
of the more disadvantaged colors like
mono red, mono white, you have to take
every piece of advantage you can get.
Every little bit, every inch, you have
to just use it. You have to maximize it.
And nothing does that better than some
of these non-basic lands. Now, Velica
Awakening is just amazing. I think this
goes into pretty much every red deck,
but here is even better because we can
uh do the
filtering. Skull smashing is a burn
stone. Why
not pinnacle
monk? Now, five mana is super expensive.
I don't usually use the front sight that
much, but with these MDFCs, the ones
from modern horizons, and also same with
shatter skull, actually, you can pay
three light for it to enter untapped.
This makes it extremely close to a
mountain. It's almost the difference is
negligible. So the opportunity cost is
low and the floor is high. So I think
there's no reason to not play these
cards. Mo this deck, this card is super
expensive when it comes to tempo and
life loss. I mean interest tapped
colorless and cost two life per tap. But
the payoff I think is worth it. Late
game. If you're tapping out for a huge
burst spell and it gets countered, your
game is pretty much over cuz your
opponent see what you can do and your
shields are down. So you don't want your
stuff countered, BU is the way. War
Room, draw cards. We need all the card
draw we can. So War Rune
is Yeah, solid choice. You only lose one
life because our commander is mono red.
It seems this card seems tailor made for
monocolor decks. This one
is what's it called? Spine rocknull.
Yeah, Spyro rock. Now, what this says is
it enters tapped, hide away four. So,
hide away means you can look at the top
four cards and put and exile one of them
under this. And when an opponent takes
seven or more damage in a turn, you can
pay one red and tap this to cast the
card hit away for free. And opponents
taking seven damage is pretty common in
our deck. And also, it works when your
opponents attack each other. So, it's
just a free value, free spell that you
can drop. Imagine dropping a mana
doubler or something like a chandra
ignition from this is
huge. Winding canyons once again flash
instant speed is excellent and our
commander is better protected if you can
flash it in, right? Flash our commander
in and then untap for a big burn spell.
So, we are protecting from sorcery speed
removals and we have indestructible.
This makes it pretty safe. like a
commander will probably stick if you do
that combination inventor
spare. I'm going to be honest, this is
used for tutoring for the one ring
basically. But in a pinch, you can also
get oblivion stone or something like a
mana doubler. Yeah, just some
incremental value. We have tempo of the
false god. Again, this card is a bit
controversial, but in our decks, we are
patient. We have time and we have lots
of ways to make sure we hit our land
drops. So, chances are we're not going
to be stuck with this and not be able to
use the mana
ability. And yeah, land adding two mana
is yeah, it's good. It's excellent. So,
crucible of defiance. Now, this doesn't
synergize much with our deck. The only
use I guess because when we get
pressured, we don't play a lot of
creatures, we get pressured, we can use
this to chop block. And also if our
opponents are playing say a flesh fake
marauder, they're edicting us. We can in
a pinch discard this to have some
plotters. It also enters on top. So just
yeah, it's basically a a
mountain myriad landscape ramp. Again,
our deck is not fast. We can afford to
take take some time to ramp to have lens
entertainment. This card is amazing
because what you can it's a graveyard
hit it's a scavenger's ground which we I
think we all thought how but at the same
time it you can pay three mana well
scavenge exile the graveyards but also
you get to return a historic card from
your graveyard. Now this includes our
commander Luggan any of the artifacts. I
mean if the one ring gets blown up yay
we get it back. Yeah this card is a
ridiculous ridiculous value. strip line
just because lands are getting better
and better nowadays. People with their
gay cradles and kebab coffers and
mabbys. Yeah, we got to blow them
up. Drowning her temple. This is because
we discard, right? If we discard
something, we want to discard this to
our commander's ability and we can pay
three then to rep. So, it's got great
synergy with what we're doing. Scavenger
grounds, like I said earlier, graveyard
hate is necessary. We need them in every
deck. And uh yeah, ideally we want them
in lands. Command beacon. If our
commander gets too expensive, we do need
to use this to bring him
back. Junk town. Yeah, this is for when
we are flooded. We get all the ramp but
no gas. We can sacrifice this pay. It's
expensive, but turn do this and we can
get we can all three cards from the top
of our deck. And this can definitely
bring us back into the game if we are
flooded. Mines of Moria. We can pay four
mana and exile three cards to create two
treasure tokens. This fits perfectly
into our strategy. Build, build, and
boom. Is that it? That's it. Now,
basics. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 20 basics. It's a bit
high, but because we have all the mana
doublers and all that, so basic count is
kind of relevant. And that's all. That
is the entire deck. So, yeah, there you
have it. This is the Sophium deck and
this is my best attempt at building a
monor red deck, monor red burn deck that
can keep up with the most powerful noncd
builds. Can it? We will find out.
Actually, we will find out on this
channel. We'll do some I have something
pretty interesting planned. But yeah,
the game plan is fairly clear,
straightforward. Do not overcommit. Do
not try not to try to avoid conflict if
possible. Build and catch people by
surprise.
Yeah, thank you for watching and again,
please subscribe and like and let me
know if this style video is something
you like to see or do you prefer me to
just uh because there's some glare on
the sleeves and there's
again a pretty different setting than
the usual deck tech videos, but I like
it just because it's like I feel like
I'm playing, you know, I'm at the LGS
chatting with a friend and it has a
different vibe. Let me know. See you.